[Music]
so you've taken a second adjusted
yourself to my look Oh address a few
things as you could tell by my haircut I
am a Thundercat and also a giant lesbian
yes of course I am of course I am
I have a side mullet of course I am
wearing a jean jacket that would only
look good on a lesbian or Matador my
point is zero
penis summer I was walking on stage not
too long ago and before I even hit the
mic before I even hit the mic this dude
sit in the front row he just yells out
at me look like a woman that doesn't
sleep with man he'll bat at me like as
if I don't know he'd be like he thought
I was gonna beg what do you mean is it
the vast field that me like he thought I
was raised at a gay island with a gay
volleyball I'd never seen a straight
person like he was gonna blow my mind
and opened my eyes here's the thing guys
I didn't choose my sexuality but I did
put on this outfit this is on purpose to
attract women and it works so if you're
a guy out there no I'm not sure if I'm
into that to you I say sir there's no
way your lesson to me than I am into you
cuz I'm not into you at all you can't
come to a lesbians yell at her as if
it's an insult you look like a woman
that doesn't sleep with men if you're a
lesbian not sleeping with men is one of
the biggest parts of being a lesbian
you're not bummed about it every night I
just go home I'm like not tonight again
you can't go up to somebody that's in a
minority group try to insult them with a
positive part of being in that minority
group can't go up to a black person to
be like I bet you don't burn in the Sun
well that's what sunscreen to my right I
gotcha
because they would be like what are you
talking about and that's how I felt that
night oh I guess I should uh are there
any um there any straight people here
okay yeah a couple of people that's okay
you don't have to feel weird this is a
safe space
honestly I'm an advocate and an ally I
want you to know that you know just to
be kind of honest and vulnerable with
you guys my parents are straight yeah so
I've seen their relationship and I know
there can be real love there I think we
can be different we should celebrate
that we shouldn't shame each other for
being different I could prove it to you
guys for one story I used to be on this
party planning committee and one day we
were going around this committee table
and everybody was suggesting things that
they wanted for this party that we were
planning and I said oh I think this
party needs whack-a-mole
I stand by that that's how on a party on
hid animatronic molds of the head with a
mallet but I said I think this party
needs whack-a-mole another lady on the
committee looks at me and she goes okay
I believe it's pronounced guacamole
oh yes yes that lady now we didn't see
the world in the same way we weren't
different I was talking about something
you'd find a check of cheese she was
writing on a Mexican appetizer that
didn't make my life worse if anything it
drastically improved it because I got to
see the world through her eyes oh and it
was a beautiful world I got to see a
world in which I am an adult woman who's
been walking into Chipotle's for years
for years just going like Oh
Wacka malls extra well how much your
jalopy knows that's who that woman
thinks I am she also thinks nobody has
ever told me do you get that like we're
in a room full of people so before she
speaks there's totally a mom or she's
like oh now he's got correct this lady
like in her mind when she speaks up she
is a hero just like the buck stops with
me I can't sleep well tonight I loved
her for it I loved her for it I didn't
correct her I didn't tell her she was
wrong I just said lady thank you very
much and that's how we should treat each
other you guys I'm Cameron Esposito
thank you so much
you